PROFESSOR: So ours was a
little different-- well,
it was actually very
different from everyone else
because ours is in 2D, and
everyone else's is in 3D.
So all we have basically
is a background,
and then you have a canvas.
AUDIENCE: Oh,
PROFESSOR: And what you can do
is-- if I can find the mouse--
you can paint on
here, for example.
And then, if you click on
eraser and then go over that,
you can erase it.
The main part of
this was supposed
to be that it's supposed
to be able to connect
with the Kinect.
And if you-- for example,
you use your right hand
to move the mouse like
they did, and then
if your left hand
goes up, it clicks
and then it's supposed to draw.
But the Kinect. would just
not connect with the thing
at all, for some reason.
So we couldn't-- it
wouldn't detect motion,
so we couldn't get it to work.
But essentially what
it does is if you
were to see when it's just
painting, it's creating a dot,
right?
So what it's basically doing
is every time you click,
it creates a dot-- and then, if
you do it like a fluid motion,
it creates a bunch of dots.
For example, if you were
to draw a lot, it's--
yeah, you see the dots.
Down here we were
going to do colors,
but we couldn't get that far.
But that's the basic project.
We were going to have something
where you could change
the canvas, and then you
can change the background
so it looks like you're
painting at the beach,
or something like that--
and so, aesthetically pleasing.
But this is as far as
we could get for now.